um connect with us in our heart spaces
and help us to be
um
vulnerable and present to the things
that we have going on in our own lives
and would this time be a holy space for
us to take inventory and see where
you're at and what you're doing
um inside of us and in the world around
us and connect with that source of love
that you have always been and will
always be for each one of us
in Jesus name
all right we're going to start out with
brighter days Josh is going to start us
out back here so you guys can follow
along and sing if you know it and if not
you're welcome to just enjoy sit back
and relax or clap use your whole body I
like holistic worship because we are
whole people so please enter in as you
feel comfortable
I feel
[Music]
I'm feeling me like the beating of life
in my things I know there's gonna be
some brighter days I know there's gonna
be some brighter days
oh ashes
oh if you if you're trying hard to
breathe
in the dark
days
[Music]
I Feel It In Me Like The Feeding of life
in my face I know there's gonna be some
brighter days
[Music]
off your screams
your screams
oh if you're welcome
[Music]
there's gonna be some brighter days
already
[Music]
know there's gonna be surprises
I
[Music]
know there's gonna be surprised
I know there's gonna be some pride today
[Music]
amen all right may it be so you kiddos
are dismissed your classrooms um if this
is your first time we have our older
Elementary's kids which is second grade
through sixth grade in this room to my
right and we have first grade down to
four years old over here I should have
done that backwards four through first
grade and then any young babies and
toddlers are back there down this
hallway on the right side
[Music]
hugging each other
all right we're gonna transition into
the prayers of the people
um this is a time where we as a
community like to hold the burdens that
we carry into this space just up before
God together and
um believe that we are a community
that's
here to walk
um this journey both the highs and the
lows and and really be a support system
for one another and we also believe that
God is here listening and he cares and
he wants to meet us in the spaces that
are hard the spaces that are challenging
so we're going to read this prayer aloud
together and then we'll leave some space
for you to just speak out a name or a
situation that you're carrying on your
heart and if you're online with us
tonight you can do that in the comments
share what you're carrying in the
comments and then we will finish out the
prayer together
would you guys read this aloud with me
Jesus for this city of Sachse Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth that you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized in those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you Lord we know that
you love us and that you hear us so we
lift these names and situations up to
you
and Jeff
King
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light healing and
hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence
foreign
before we start the song
I was debating on whether or not I was
going to say something and I'm going to
because maybe I'll get all my emotion
out now so that I can actually sing the
song
um
my parents are here and there's some I
love my dad a lot there's something
about a mom when you do something
emotional you see her you just start
crying
so knowing she's here I'm just gonna
spill the beans so I can get through the
song hopefully but my relationship with
this song is really tough I realized in
practice tonight
we did a run through after practicing
through it and uh it just hit me and I
just I couldn't
sing some of these words and afterwards
I was telling the team and I just broke
down and I haven't cried like that
it was short-lived but I didn't I
haven't cried like that in a long time
but a little over a year ago my sweet
niece was diagnosed with cancer
we're on the other side she's
cancer-free so I'll leave for that yeah
thank you
but this song
like I was mad I still am mad at God
about that I haven't resolved that and
this song was
difficult to play
and I realized tonight I hadn't played
it since I mean maybe I have but I
hadn't played it in the sense of
thinking about these words and what they
mean and I was playing tonight and just
visions of my knees just kept
going through my head
and I realized I had a lot of anger
um the songs I raise the Hallelujah and
I couldn't do that in that in that
context by knowing that she was sick
and not understanding you know there's
no reason for it
so I just want to share that you're my
family
and then my mom and Dad are here and
they're definitely my family
so I just want to share that uh
hopefully I can get through it but I
wanted you to connect to the emotion
that I have to this song
um and if you can raise a Hallelujah in
a trying time then you know teach me how
to do that because I want to learn as
well so
I raise a Hallelujah
in the presence of my enemies
[Music]
I raise a
Hallelujah
and louder than the unbelief
birthday
I raised Hallelujah
my weapon is a melody
[Music]
I reason s Hallelujah
fight for me
[Music]
store
louder and louder
[Music]
and louder
bring it to
internet
[Music]
instead of me
Hallelujah
[Music]
I raise a Hallelujah
Hallelujah
[Music]
that I'm gonna see
hope will arise
[Music]
death is defeated the king is alive
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
sing a little louder
[Music]
[Applause]
in the presence of my enemies
[Music]
[Applause]
fight for me sing a little louder
[Music]
[Applause]
hope will arise
[Music]
the king is alive
thank you for space
for both grief and joy
thank you for being present in our every
moment God
[Music]
is
so here's my heart
Lord
Here's My Heart Lord
speak a word is true sing that again
hears My Heart Lord
speak a word is true
cause I am found
I am yours
I am loved
I'm a pure
I have life
I can breathe
I am healed
I am free
[Music]
thank you
Here's My Heart Lord
[Music]
speak what is true cause I am found
I am yours
I am love
love I'm a pure
I have my life
I can breathe
I am here
I am free cause you are strong
you are sure
you are life
you endure
you were good
always true
you are like
breaking through
[Music]
my heart
is
[Music]
true here's my life
Lord
[Applause]
hears my life Lord
[Music]
life Lord
s
is true
[Music]
foreign
you were good
always true
[Music]
[Applause]
things
[Music]
Here's My Heart Lord
here's my heart
Lord
[Music]
speak the word is true
here's my life Lord
speak a word is true
[Music]
God we open up our hearts and our life
to you and your love and your ways
we give ourselves over to the path of
Jesus
that loved unconditionally
that made space and room for each person
and their story
to the voice of love that laid down its
life
for the least of these
God we make room to make ourselves
not the center of the universe
but a part of your bigger picture
[Music]
God the way that you served
would it be an example to us and would
we model Our Lives after it
the way that you made space at the table
God would our lives look like that
would we be the first to invite in The
Outsider
[Music]
to love the unlovely
foreign
[Music]
God would you have our have your way
with us
would you have first place in our hearts
[Music]
would you change us and transform us
thank you God
for A Love That Never Ends
it's in your name we pray and ask these
things
amen
I hope that God met you somewhere in
that would you guys take a second to
turn to the people around you make them
feel welcomed and at home introduce
yourself if you haven't met them before
and then Brett will get us started on
our message
well Grace and peace
it is so good to be with you all welcome
to the table
um my name is Brett and uh
I want to extend a warm welcome to each
and every one of you and as always that
includes those joining us online love
y'all lots and anyone here who is new
tonight thank you for for being with us
we're really really glad that you're
here
um so we are in Let's see we are in part
four
in our series titled the Book of James
um if you haven't been with us for every
um
message in the series that's fine
they're kind of each you know Standalone
we're basically just making our way
through a really I should say covering
major themes of this early book from the
New Testament and it is uh it's an
incredibly practical book we got into a
lot of that um last week and in ways
you'll you can tell throughout the
series that um just the themes you know
it's not a lot of like super in-depth
um theology it's
um you know it's like practical
practical stuff very practical so
um I want to
start with I'll only give you the title
so it's the title is I'm waking up to
words
is the title of the message and our
passage is from James chapter 2 verses
two through eight which says this we all
stumble in many ways
anyone who is never at fault in what
they say is perfect able to keep their
whole body in check when we put bits
into the mouths of horses to make them
obey us we can turn the whole animal
or take shifts as an example although
they're so large and are driven by
strong winds they're steered by a very
small Rudder wherever the pilot wants to
go likewise the tongue is a small part
of the body but it makes great boasts
consider what a great Forest is set on
fire by a small spark the tongue also is
a fire a world of evil among the parts
of the body it corrupts the whole body
it's that's the whole course of one's
life on fire it is itself set on fire by
hell all kinds of animals and birds and
reptiles and sea creatures are being
tamed and have been tamed by mankind
but no human being can tame the tongue
it is a Restless evil full of deadly
poison
happy happy happy happy happy happy
happy
well then we'll get more into some of
this negativity later
um this is the fascinating passage
um I want to start by uh talking about
there's this delightful interview
that I listen to I guess the podcast
um between Lex Friedman he's kind of a
popular you know podcaster out there
um well I'm hearing a little feedback
um
Stephen just let me know if I need to
switch mics I can
um
so list between Lex Friedman and he
interviewed um Yuval Harari whose uh
famous author he wrote the book sapiens
and then homo Deus
um to really insightful good books um
Harare
um I think I think Jewish and upbringing
but um now in in atheist
um and that comes out very strongly in
his um his books but still I mean
they're really brilliant
um so it's yeah Lex Friedman an MIT
researcher and actually does a lot with
AI and then he's interviewing Yuval
Harare so um fascinating interview but
the part that really stood out to me was
um this part where they were it was
basically harare's take on AI artificial
intelligence and kind of you know these
large language learning models we have
with like chat GPT taking the World by
storm a few of you using chat GPT out
there and you're like yep the machines
are taken over
it's happening
um and uh
so Harare is he's quite
um skeptical about where all that's
headed and
um
now where I see kind of a connection
between these two on this podcast and uh
and then this this passage in James is
not only the negativity which came out
very strongly with Harare in his
interview and of course as I kind of
reference comes out well you didn't miss
it I mean it comes out very strongly in
um this passage from James you know he
sounds like he's not a fan of the tongue
you know
um
but even deeper than that it's not just
that they're both kind of negative about
it it's even deeper is um the connection
of why like why are they so negative
and here is where it seems to me even
though they're talking about sort of
separate things
um it seems to me that they are in
perfect agreement
um you see perhaps the kind of
counterbalance harari's negativity at
one point
um Friedman who like I mentioned is like
he does work on AI himself so you know
he said like um he was sympathetic to
Ferrari's kind of criticisms but um like
for example Harare just to give you a
feel for where he's coming from he
mentions that he's really worried about
the way Bots are impersonating people
um this is already happening like if you
go on Twitter you don't even know if
you're like chatting you know I mean
replying to is this even a real you can
just be having a fake conversation you
know I really just completely just an AI
or language but I have a friend sweet
friend like he um he's not he's not tech
savvy
um and so he he's he has lived a lot of
his life alone he's quite lonely and he
mentioned to me that uh a woman even
having a conversation with a woman
online
on Facebook
and I had to let him know like I kind of
hinted at like has she at all like asked
you for money
and he's like yeah how did you know that
and I was like oh buddy
okay yeah she's probably not actually
real like a real person you know like
that's the world you know what I mean so
that's why Harare that's where he's come
from so to kind of counterbalance this
though
um Friedman kind of pushes back a little
bit it's like well but but there is a
lot of good right there's a lot of good
that could come from AI you know
and someone surprisingly because you
wouldn't guess it by his tone
um Harari is like oh of course
oh of course I mean my goodness like it
wouldn't be developed as a technology
if we didn't think we just thought like
oh this is going to be terrible let's do
it you know like no of course it could
be lots of good you know and he
mentioned a few things and such you know
kind of eliminating maybe jobs that
would be dreary and Troublesome that
letting humans do other things instead
you know
um
and what came out as he talked though I
realized and this is again the
connection I see is
um I think when someone's really
negative we tend to think well it's
because they just hate that thing you
know it's just like oh it's just because
it's bad bad it's all bad
um but actually the reason for example
Harare is kind of really critical of AI
is not because he hates it
um but because he's aware of its power
that's the key
he is aware of its power
and in fact
um at one point he gives an example he
says no one ever cared about a weak
technology
you know like hey I've got this new tech
honestly it can't do anything you know
like okay I mean we just who cares you
know I mean like don't worry it's
utterly harmless
and also can't do a lick of good you
know it's just like okay I guess that's
right that's the trick
is the more powerful it is
the more capable it is of what both
tremendous good yes but also what
tremendous harm evil like because that's
that's the thing it's so powerful it's
and that's why Harare is negative and as
I that's where it came back to me as I'm
reading the book of James in the past
few weeks is I think um that's where
James is coming from like in the passage
if you just kind of like if you listen
to Harare you just be like this guy
hates AI you know and if you just listen
to James you're like he hates speech
he's just like I wish we could just not
talk at all
um but but it's actually I don't think
it's it's quite that that simple now of
course it is
to be fair it is negative though I mean
he's really intense we can just I'll
just picked out a few of these phrases
this is James on the tongue talking
about speech he says it makes great both
verse five it's a fire it's a world of
evil it corrupts the whole body it is
itself set on fire it it sets the whole
course of your life on fire it is a
Restless evil it's full of deadly poison
no human being can tame the tongue right
so it just sounds like he he hates it
um and yet if you look back just a
little bit I think there's kind of signs
like although James he isn't coming out
and giving some sort of balanced
argument he's not explaining in the way
exactly I am um I do think there's hints
though
like on the one hand at the end I think
I think it's somewhat hyperbolic but for
good reason like he says you know no
human being contain the tongue
you know I mean just like that's pretty
strong
um and yet I do think there's like at
least a little hope maybe not a lot of
folk
um and I mean if you look at world
history probably there's not a reason
you know for like a ton of Hope on this
front but I do think James has at least
a little hope that perhaps by God's
grace
um
people who love Christ might just learn
to tame the tongue a little bit
um
and the metaphors you see them there's
in in the beginning verse three and four
he says when we put bits into the mouths
of horses to make them obey us we can
turn the whole animal
right so you've got this little thing
just right in the mouth and just like
that all of a sudden you've got this
technology right it just
last year this giant animal
um or then he finds it even better
metaphor he says or take shifts as an
example
although they are so large
and are driven by strong winds they're
steered by what
it's like just this this little small
Rudder wherever the pilot wants to go
driving at here although he didn't you
know then he shifts into really negative
mode and it's just like damn this tongue
is insane you know
um but I do wonder if we just take those
metaphors like maybe maybe he does have
like a little bit of Hope
um
but it is the little because just like
you know whatever the technology AI or
the internet or you know and we've seen
this play out you know like I think of a
technology and it's so powerful and it
changes everything you know it sort of
like has the computer been good for
Humanity
you know and it's sort of like
um yeah yes I think or it's complicated
you know what I mean like or the
internet has the internet been a win
I
see you know I mean it's just it's
probably and I think in a similar way
it's almost like if we could go back
and sort of Imagine This Time like of
course this conversation never happened
because it wouldn't even be possible
um because they have to have speech but
I'm just imagine if someone like
invented speech like the first person
you know whatever again this is a
ridiculous scenario because you have to
use speech to talk about Spirit okay but
you get it like just imagine if they're
like I got this new tech you know it's
like these these words like
speak these words in it and you
understand and it like oh my gosh it's
amazing it's it's so powerful like it
could just be incredible like you know I
mean and at first I could just imagine
everyone's like
oh my gosh
this is huge he's like imagine you could
write the words like if we you know I
mean like you can see where this kind of
played out through human oh my God like
incredible incredible possibilities good
good good all good nothing but good
amazing communication it's gonna be
great right
and how's it played out it's like
oh it's
it is it's really powerful
it's really powerful
both for good
and for tremendous evil
and and I think that's that's that's
kind of what I'm I'm wanting us to start
to get like if I had just one big idea
for tonight it would be this wake up
wake up to the power of your words like
that's what I'm trying to get you to see
is like see him afresh in a new you know
because that's the thing you're just
sort of born in the world and then you
know you just start learning to speak
and it's just you just we do we just
take it for granted don't we it's just I
don't know just I am who I am I speak
the way I speak say the words I want to
say it's just how I always said it and
just kind of goes through the world just
do my thing you know just never even a
second thought I mean I don't know about
you I don't spend a lot of time like wow
my speech it's
the power of speech is so it's so so
powerful so wow I should really analyze
my words this week I wonder let me do
some journal entries on the words I've
spoken and how the good or the bad those
might be bringing it I mean I don't know
about you I don't do that at all it
means almost like a technology that just
kind of moved to the world just like
dirt didn't hurt you know and just
speaking throwing out words here and
there typing it right you know and just
kind of throwing it out there and that's
where I think you see the beauty even
though it's a hard word it's sort of the
power of what James is getting at is
he's like no no no no no no no no no
stop
stop it
like slow it down
do you realize the power you have
like these words they they build
um I mean realities
they they make Nations and they tear
them down you know they build
relationships and they shred them to
pieces
it's just
on I mean you think AI is powerful
you know like that's got nothing at
least not yet on words
like wow like this is the most
incredible I mean we talk a lot about
smartphones like hey be smart about your
you know your smartphones you gotta
think about you know and I'd agree with
all that like we knew we need to think
about is the technology has come in our
lives we often don't analyze it you know
but in the meantime we have this like
ancient using the word metaphorically
Technologies so to speak words
but we don't think about that
because it's just I don't know I've just
always had it
always saying words
is that does that kind of make sense
um
in other words
um I think we need to wake up to our
words and we need to notice just start
noticing
like the the power that's in them
because here's like the good news that
James doesn't really get into but I'm
I'm offering it for him
um is
Elevate the speech
Elevate the person
Elevate the speech it's this virtuous
cycle upwards
right and it can be incredibly powerful
like remarkably powerful in people's
lives I talked a few weeks ago about
um
my own history in like sports and kids
sports activities and such and I was I
did swimming but I also did baseball
and uh I can still remember my parents
like my mom especially she was like very
vocal but in a good way like cheering me
on just like yeah yeah you know and my
brother cheering me on and uh I was a
pitcher
and I would take it far too seriously oh
my gosh I I might as well then pitch in
the world's theories I was so nervous
you know it's like 10 year old baseball
and I'm just like
and I'll never forget my dad would like
consistently he would take me aside
maybe because he could see my little
anxious 10 year old self and he would
take me aside he would put his hands on
my shoulders
and look right in my eyes
and he would say Brett win or lose
I love you
win or lose
yo those words were like
Magic
to a little ten-year-old's ears
and and I wonder like when I was
received in that moment right it was
more than the words
right it was it was
um how they made me feel you know what
they communicated I'm here for you I
support you I'm on your side you know
like
that's the that's the magic that can
happen with the words that we speak
I think another
um
kind of interesting example for my own
life and upbringing
um so getting married was such even
though I knew my wife Maggie for many
years before we got married but it was
still a shock because there's always the
culture clash of the two families coming
together you know and I'm the tilfords
she was the Burgesses and these two
families I do this they're not they
don't we don't fight we just it was um
it was very different you know like her
family is like all about like they were
Enneagram numbers if you're in an
Instagram they would be two family just
like service and good deeds and action
you know like they would love my sermon
last week it was all about action you
know and doing things and like let's
let's get to work here you know
um now the strength of the children we
can do a thing you know after we talk
about it for a while you know we want to
think about it and really analyze you
know and dream now this comes to the the
string now this is the I probably would
just drive some people bananas but on
the good side was um I can still have
these I remember sitting in my
um we'd eat dinner so late I think
because it was after swim practice so
we're eating like eight o'clock at night
we're sitting in the living room and
there's my mom my mom and dad would do
this but especially my mom and she would
dream with us
like did your parents say this with you
I don't know this is normal like let's
just let's just talk about your dreams
what do you what do you want to be what
do you want to do what what
possibilities could the future hold
like and we would sit there for hours
like just talking maybe I want to do
that maybe I want you know now the um as
I've seen kind of how this has played
out like I've had to learn in my life
like some doing and some serving and
some like you know okay
um
and but if there's many criticisms of
the Tilford boys my brother and I um
Josh and I
um and there are many but if I don't
think anyone could ever say those boys
you know they lack self-confidence I had
no confidence in them like no and I
really think something that came from we
just our parents like believed in us
down to their toes and we're like we can
do anything you know
um maybe even to like delusional levels
perhaps
um but still there was like there was
such beauty in that
and and what do you what was it like it
was just words
but there's no such thing as just words
like you elevate Elevate speech I like
the words you elevate the person you
elevate the person you elevate the
speech it's this virtuous powerful cycle
upwards of course the danger is that the
reverse is also true isn't it
I can recall I was maybe about 25 26
working in a corporate world
and um I would go outside to eat
and I was put on this bench and there
was a large hedge and on the other side
of the Hedge was a picnic table but the
Hedge was thick enough you could not see
through it
and I I it's a weird like this this
memory is you know almost 15 years old
now
um
and I'll never forget it was some men
came they sat down
and they began to speak
of course they didn't know I was on the
other side they thought they were alone
and I will never forget
the the words that they said like you
know
it was it was um
toxic
they were talking about the women in
their life
they were speaking
some of them co-workers that they worked
with
uh
they're speaking about them and
like objectifying them
um saying what they've done to them what
they were going to do like it was
the worst of like a sort of masculinity
gone terribly wrong you know
um it was that like and I've been around
you know locker rooms and whatever like
I was you know it's not like they were
saying curse words it was so offensive
you know I'm not talking about curse
words like it was just like honestly I
don't think I've ever like I was full-on
deconstruction mode I don't even know if
I believed in hell at that point you
know but like I was suddenly like
listening to them speak I just knew in
my soul I was like oh no
oh no like this is the speech like this
talk this leads to hell like this is
it's bad
it was bad I wish I had more courage
like I would have gone around that hedge
you know maybe now a 39 year old
Bradfield what is going on with you
gentlemen like you know like
oh my god
um
see in the same way you can Elevate the
speech Elevate the person also what you
degrade the speech you degrade the
person degrade the person degrade the
speech it's this Vicious Circle
downwards it's incredibly incredibly
dangerous so we've gotta wake up to the
words that we're saying now this leads
to the Natural question of how
um how do we do that
and
um
I think I'm going to try to keep it
simple maybe we could just start
well maybe let me frame it like this if
if
really degrading speech is like a river
and we're here on one side of the bank
and we're kind of struggling with our
words and then over here is like The
Virtuous cycle you know we want every
word that drops from our mouths to be
like Precious the jewels bringing life
to all people you know okay so that's
where we want to be but we're like not
there
um the question is how do we get there
and I think we often want to get there
by just like you know what
everything's going to be different from
here on from tonight onward just like a
kid at Youth Camp you know just this is
it my life is different forever and I
swear it you know
um and it's like okay maybe
um so maybe maybe what we need is like a
bridge practice you know so here's the
bridge practice maybe
maybe quieter than usual
you know what I mean like and I really
am not joking like you know in essence
instead of like I'm always gonna speak
nothing but good you know instead maybe
it's like I'm gonna work on shedding up
you know I mean like just
they just hold like holding the tongue
right this is what James calls taming
the tongue you start by taming the
tongue by learning to just I just
there is a um
a Christian monkey would later become
known as Abba agathon
and
um in his later years he was like really
this is some iconography about him he
was known as like one of the leaders of
the desert fathers and mothers an
incredible incredible man like known for
his compassion his wisdom perspective he
was revered
um in very very early Christian
centuries however when he was a younger
man
he really struggled with the words that
he would say it was as James talks about
set on fire by hell he was like kind of
the worst and but something in him like
he wanted to change he wanted to be
different
and so you know what he did for three
years he got a stone
and he placed it in his mouth
and he kept that stone in his mouth for
three years now I don't know if he like
I mean the man had to eat
so I'm assuming and I don't know if he
kept silence for three years and just
would eat and then put it back in or if
he would take it out to speak but then
the very Act of doing that you know sort
of forces
awareness
you know which is often what we're
lacking in speech I mean we always have
perspective 24 hours later
sometimes even just
24 seconds later you know like
that wasn't the best you know
um
so I don't know exactly his practice but
something and I think like what a
powerful example of like oh I want to
tame the tongue like Lord by your grace
help me tame the tongue now am I
suggesting like I have a little ushers
can we hand out the stones you know no
uh I'm not I don't have stones for you
to do that I think that's probably a
choking hazard and I don't want to be
held liable
um so I don't actually suggest that
seems really dangerous but
um I was thinking like what could maybe
be like inching towards you know that
what could be sort of a metaphorical
Stone and I thought you know what if we
took one day maybe we just start with
this coming week one day
to really pay attention to your speech
and to try to avoid all um any words
spoken from anger hostility
rage Envy jealousy hatred complaining
that's a hard one now the good news is
it's only going to be 99 degrees this
week instead of one I know some of y'all
have been struggling with some
complaining I have
um it's been really hot
um but but the beauty of this practice
right is you just take one day
and then maybe you could even say like
you know what for me it's going to be
Mondays like I'm going to be aware of
what I say
and then who knows like that awareness
practice suddenly like it starts kind of
making its way into the rest of your
week
I did this a few years back with um or
not years I did this maybe six months
ago with complaining
I try to take a few days and not I try
to do like three days without
complaining
now like I consider myself like I don't
think of myself as much of a complainer
wrong I'm like a big baby like I am
complaining all the time nothing's right
in my life you know it's just constant
like it's so tempting it was I found it
unbelievably difficult which is why I'm
suggesting one day like I don't even
saying try this weekly I'm just saying
what if you just try it for one day and
then after that as God leads you know
because like it is no joke it's an
arduous process but
um
boy for following Jesus how important
are our words
as Christians as parents as friends as
co-workers
how important are our words and what
could God do with the community of
people who who are committed to
consecrate that's a that's a churchy
word but to consecrate their speech to
to say God every word I say is yours
would you change and Transform Me
but I I think that would be
amazing what God would do in our
community in your families in your
relationships
may may we all have transformed speech
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit amen
so as we
come to the table of the Lord tonight as
we take in the body of Christ and the
bread the blood of Christ and the wine
as I thought about communion I couldn't
help but notice what do we do
right to the mouth you know
and it's it my kind of my prayers you
come forward tonight is that it would be
an act done in Awareness that as you
take in Christ that there would be a
prayer even of God heal my words I've
been given this unbelievable gift
um heal my speech
so that's kind of the heart posture as
we as we come forward tonight on the way
we'll do this we'll just start in the
front row
with Mindy no one else is here so it'll
be you go first and we'll just kind of
do row by row and make our way back
um we practice what's called an Open
Table meaning if you're here tonight and
you want to participate then you are
free to do that regardless of you know
your exact theological beliefs or
denominational this or that or whatever
you know just if you want to participate
you can feel free to do that having said
that
um there's no pressure to participate if
you're in a place where you you would
rather not that's okay too
um the red is wine the white is grape
juice so
just be aware we're very hardcore church
and
um and then finally you can just partake
whenever you'd like so I won't come back
up and like lead you through the taking
the elements you know you just you can
take immediately you can return to your
seat and partake just however you'd like
to do that so this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow in you who
have failed
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here come to
the table
[Music]
foreign
thank you Brett
I do want to give my perspective on
something my brother said
one is my friend I was not dreaming I
was planning
when Mom would sit us down I was making
plans some of them happened some of them
did not so maybe I was fantasizing
yeah taming the tongue is it's easier
said than done isn't it
going into this next song this last song
you can stay see it if you want this is
really a
it's a blessing
to you as we journey
and really it's a promise
This song is called find the light our
very own Jesse Watts recommended it to
us
the David Ramirez song It's Beautiful
lyrics I'm sad Jess he's not here to
witness its
first time being sung together
[Music]
but yeah this song it talks about
finding the light and it's not if it's
you will
So for anybody who needs encouragement
for anybody who's
been on the road and you're feeling it
and you're getting back into the school
year or whatever it is that's going on
outside this building
this song is a promise
to everyone here
and everyone
out there too
a wish upon you peace
wish upon you Grace
I Wish For Less of what you want and
more of what you need
I wish upon you an old life
a heart that stays Young
most of all I wish upon you love
A Wish Upon Your Truth
when all you feel is doubt
hope you know that an open mind still
knows when to shut things out
I wish upon you a brave heart will
always rise above most of all I wish
upon you love
and as the sun sets sun says and the
moon begins to rise
even in the darkness you'll find the
light
you'll find the light alive
you'll find
yes even in the darkness you'll find the
light
I wish upon you an easy life I wish upon
you hard times I hope you know the full
Joy and Pain each need their moment to
shine I wish you years that are quick to
listen and slowly use that tongue
most of all I wish upon you love
as the sun and as the sun sets and the
moon begins to rise
[Music]
you'll find the love
you'll find
[Applause]
[Music]
yes even in the Darkness
you'll find love
[Applause]
you'll find
[Music]
you'll find love
[Applause]
[Music]
who you'll find
yes even in the darkness you'll find the
life
[Music]
whatever they do to keep everything
moving so smoothly
if you are new here we would love for
you to fill out a card in the hallway we
just want to welcome you know who you
are
Brett can reach out to you and just give
you information on anything you need if
you are in need of a hug or a prayer
anything I'm here my hugs are free so
come get one I love giving hugs
hugged by little kids all day so I'd
love some adult hugs
just a reminder about the workshop we
have coming up it's called under the
queer Umbrella by the sharp Wellness
Center they will be hosting it here and
it's for families of the lgbtq plus
Community to answer questions and just
have a safe a safe place to talk about
anything you need and so we'd love to
gauge your interest on that you can scan
the QR code for more information and to
let us know if you're interested or not
here at the table we're always trying to
be inclusive one of those key components
is generosity so we would love your
financial support if you are able to
give you can go to the
tabletx.org or donate in the hallway and
we would be super grateful thank you
um
about the tongue the word it's
incredible that the tongue can change
the course of an entire life just this
little tiny tongue can change your
entire life and as a teacher I'm always
trying to tell my kids about the Power
of Words and being on the receiving end
you can find someone's words years later
in your mind and you know they stick
with you so just be conscious of that
this week the words you're saying and
the things that that you're telling
people because it can speak life to
people or it can bring them down so just
I encourage you to notice your words
this week lastly I would like to send
you out with a benediction if you
wouldn't mind before we go into this
week and you start going home thinking
about your crazy schedules if you guys
would just take a breath with me that
would be lovely thank
[Music]
you
I hope these words bless you
you are a child of God you are a child
of God this is true on your best day and
it's also true on your worst day so as
you go into your week ahead with its yet
to be determined highs and lows and
everything in between go filled with the
assurance that you are loved you are
worthy and you are perfect Just As You
Are
go filled with the assurance
go sorry go filled with God's Holy
Spirit and the desire to extend these
same Gifts of Grace and unconditional
love with everyone you come into contact
with this week
remember your words you are blessed and
I hope you have a wonderful night and I
will see you next Sunday thank you
everybody good night
[Music]
alive
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign